>>> WELCOME TO "CNN TONIGHT."
I'M JAKE TAPPER IN WASHINGTON.
AND TONIGHT NEW HORRIFIC DETAILS
ARE EMERGING ABOUT THE ATTEMPTED
VIOLENT ATTACK AGAINST HOUSE
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI, THE ONE
THAT ENDED WITH THE WOUNDING AND
HOSPITALIZATION OF HER HUSBAND,
PAUL PELOSI.
THE ALLEGED VIOLENT INTRUDER
DAVID DePAPE IS FACING FEDERAL
CHARGES FOR BREAKING INTO THE
PELOSI'S HOME AND BEATING PAUL
PELOSI WITH A HAMMER EARLY
FRIDAY MORNING.
THE SUSPECT WHO TRAFFICKED
ONLINE IN FAR RIGHT CONSPIRACY
THEORIES ABOUT COVID AND THE
2020 ELECTION AND HOLOCAUST
DENIALISM, QUOTE, STATED THAT HE
WAS GOING TO HOLD NANCY HOSTAGE
AND TALK TO HER.
IF NANCY WERE TO TELL DePAPE THE
TRUTH, HE WOULD LET HER GO.
AND IF SHE LIED, HE WAS GOING TO
BREAK HER KNEECAPS.
DePAPE ALSO EXPLAINED, SHE WOULD
THEN HAVE TO BE WHEELED INTO
CONGRESS, WHICH WOULD SHOW OTHER
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS THERE WERE
CONSEQUENCES TO ACTIONS,
UNQUOTE.
SEVERAL PROMINENT REPUBLICANS
HAVE CONDEMNED THE ATTACK,
INCLUDING TODAY DONALD TRUMP.
>> WITH PAUL PELOSI, THAT'S A
TERRIBLE THING.
WITH ALL OF THEM, IT'S A THE
RECORDABLE THING.
>> TRUMP VERY QUICKLY PIVOTED TO
ATTACKING SAN FRANCISCO FOR ITS
HIGH CRIME RATE, BUT HE AT LEAST
DID CONDEMN THE ATTACK ON PAUL
PELOSI, AS DID HOUSE REPUBLICAN
LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY.
>> LET ME BE PERFECTLY CLEAR,
VIOLENCE OR THREAT OF VIOLENCE
HAS NO PLACE IN OUR SOCIETY.
AND WHAT HAPPENED TO PAUL PELOSI
IS WRONG.
>> AS DID SENATE MINORITY LEADER
MITCH McCONNELL, WHO TWEETED HE
IS, QUOTE, HORRIFIED AND
DISGUSTED BY THE REPORTS THAT
PAUL PELOSI WAS ASSAULTED.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
FAR TOO MANY OTHER REPUBLICANS
AND CONSERVATIVE LEADERS ARE OUT
THERE INSTEAD SPREADING INSANE,
OFFENSIVE, AND FALSE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, SUCH AS THE COMPLETE
AND UTTER LIE, THE DERANGED
SMEAR THAT PAUL PELOSI AND THE
ATTACKER, THE MAN WHO HIT HIM IN
THE HEAD WITH A HAMMER, WITH IN
A SEXUAL RELATIONSHIP.
TO HIS 8.7 MILLION TWITTER
FOLLOWERS, DONALD TRUMP JR.
SHARED AN IMAGE OF A HAMMER AND
A PAIR OF UNDERWEAR THAT HAD THE
CAPTION, GOT MY PAUL PELOSI
HALLOWEEN COSTUME READY.
HE ALSO POSTED SOMETHING ELSE,
WHICH HE QUICKLY DELETED, A
SOUTH PARKESQUE CARTOON IMAGE
SUPPOSEDLY OF PELOSI AND THE GUY
WHO HIT HIM IN THE HEAD WITH A
HAMMER HAVING SEX.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
WHEN SOME SICK MORON SENT A
WHITE POUD TORE THE HOME DONALD
TRUMP JR. IN 2018 SENDING HIS
THEN-WIFE VANESSA TO THE
HOSPITAL AS A PRECAUTION, THAT
WAS AWFUL.
WHY IS THIS NOT EVEN WORSE?
IT'S HARD TO FATHOM THAT A
TRAGEDY LIKE WHAT HAPPENED TO
82-YEAR-OLD PAUL PELOSI AND
DECIDES TO TRAFFIC IN THIS
FILTH.
BUT SADLY, DONALD TRUMP JR. IS
HARDLY ALONE.
FORMER REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN
AND CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE, DEVIN
NUNEZ, WHO NOW RUNS TRUMP'S
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANY, TRUTH
SOCIAL, SHARED THIS HALLOWEEN
IMAGE WITH THE WORDS, AT LEAST
THIS GUY HAS HIS CLOTHES ON.
NUNEZ ALSO REPOSTED THIS MEME
USING A POSTER FOR THE GAY
ROMANTIC COMEDY, BROS, TWISTING
IT INTO A SMEAR OF PAUL PELOSI.
AND AGAIN, THE MAN WHO TRIED TO
BASH PELOSI'S HEAD IN WITH A
HAMMER.
WORDS FAIL.
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN CLAY
HIGGINS OF LOUISIANA TWEETED,
THEN DELETED, THIS, WHICH WAS
CAPTURED BY STEVE HER MAN, A
PHOTO OF NANCY PELOSI WITH
QUOTE, THE MOMENT YOU REALIZE
THAT NUDIST HIPPY GUY WAS THE
REASON YOUR HUSBAND DIDN'T MAKE
IT TO YOUR FUND-RAISER.
I MEAN, WHAT IS WRONG WITH THESE
PEOPLE?
THERE'S MORE, BUT YOU GET THE
POINT.
IN ADDITION TO BEING INHUMAN AND
INHUMANE RESPONSE TO A TRAGEDY,
IT'S A LIE.
THE FEDERAL AFFIDAVIT RELEASED
THIS AFTERNOON SAYS PELOSI DID
NOT KNOW THE SUSPECT.
AND SAN FRANCISCO POLICE CHIEF
BILL SCOTT SAID THIS ON CNN THIS
AFTERNOON.
>> THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO
EVIDENCE THAT MR. PELOSI KNEW
THIS MAN.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, THE
EVIDENCE INDICATES THE EXACT
OPPOSITE.
>> SADLY, IN THIS ERA OF SOCIAL
MEDIA, AFTER EVERY TRAGEDY LIKE
THIS, WE UNFORTUNATELY SEE SOME
AWFUL REACTIONS.
A VOLUNTEER OFFICIAL FOR THE
NEBRASKA DEMOCRATIC PARTY WAS
FIRED AFTER SAYING HE WAS GLAD
REPUBLICAN LEADER STEVE SCALISE
WAS SHOT BY A DERANGED BERNIE
SANDERS SUPPORTER IN 2017.
THAT SAME YEAR, THERE WERE SOME
PRETTY AWFUL COMMENTS ON SOCIAL
MEDIA AFTER REPUBLICAN SENATOR
RAND PAUL'S NEIGHBOR ATTACKED
HIM, BREAKING SIX OF HIS RIBS,
BRUISING HIS LUNGS, MAKING IT
DIFFICULT FOR HIM TO BREATHE,
SENDING RAND PAUL TO THE
HOSPITAL.
AND THREE YEARS LATER,
COMMENTING ON A CONTROVERSY
INVOLVING SENATOR PAUL, ONE OF
SPEAKER PELOSI'S DAUGHTERS
TWEETED THAT RAND PAUL'S
NEIGHBOR WAS RIGHT.
SHE THEN DELETED IT.
ALL OF THESE COMMENTS
UNEQUIVOCALLY WRONG.
BUT THESE SMEARS ABOUT PAUL
PELOSI, THEY'RE NOT JUST
EVIDENCE OF PARTISANSHIP
BLOCKING SOMEONE'S ABILITY TO BE
HUMAN.
THEY'RE CONSPIRATORIAL.
THEY'RE IN A WAY AN ATTEMPT TO
NOT JUST DOWN PLAY BUT JUSTIFY
THE VIOLENCE.
THEY'RE PART OF THE SAME
SICKNESS THAT GOT PAUL PELOSI
INJURED TO BEGIN WITH.
SOME OF THESE INSANE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES ABOUT PAUL PELOSI ARE
STILL TRENDING ON TWITTER UNDER
ITS NEW BILLIONAIRE OWNER, ELON
MUSK.
WE SHOULD NOTE, MUSK HIMSELF
SENT A TWEET THAT PUSHED THIS
FALSE SMEAR OF PELOSI.
RESPONDING TO A TWEET FROM
HILLARY CLINTON IN WHICH SHE
CONDEMNED THE ATTACK, AS
INSPIRED BY HATEFUL RHETORIC,
ELON MUSK, WHO HAS MORE THAN 110
MILLION FOLLOWERS ON TWITTER,
WROTE, QUOTE, THERE MIGHT BE
MORE TO THE STORY THAN MEETS THE
EYE, UNQUOTE.
AND THEN HE SHARED A LINK TO AN
EXTREME RIGHT-WING WEBSITE, A
SITE SO DERANGED IT CLAIMED IN
2016 THAT HILLARY CLINTON HAD
DIED AND A BODY DOUBLE HAD BEEN
SENT TO DEBATE DONALD TRUMP.
HERE'S WHAT ELON MUSK SAID IN
APRIL ABOUT WHAT HE WANTS
TWITTER TO BE.
>> WE WANT TO BE JUST VERY
RELUCTANT TO DELETE THINGS AND
HAVE -- JUST BE VERY CAUTIOUS
WITH PERMANENT BANS.
>> IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE AN INCLUSIVE ARENA FOR FREE
SPEECH.
TWITTER HAS BECOME KIND OF THE
DEFACTO TOWN SQUARE.
>> THERE IS A VAST DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN ELON MUSK WANTING
TWITTER TO LEAN MORE INTO THE
FREEST SPEECH POSSIBLE AND ELON
MUSK HIMSELF ABUSING THOSE FREE
SPEECH RIGHTS BY SMEARING PEOPLE
WITH A COMPLETE AND UTTER LACK
OF CAUTION.
THERE IS SUCH A THING AS
EMPIRICAL TRUTH, AND IT IS NOT
TO BE FOUND AT THE WEBSITE THAT
REPORTED HILLARY CLINTON DEAD
SIX YEARS AGO.
NATIONAL SECURITY EXPERTS HAVE
BEEN WARNING FOR YEARS THAT WE
IN THE UNITED STATES NEED TO
FEAR MORE STOCHASTIC TERRORISM.
IN CASE YOU'RE NOT FAMILIAR WITH
THE TERM STOCHASTIC, IT'S
DEFINED AS THE PUBLIC
DEMONIZATION OF A PERSON OR A
GROUP THAT RESULTS IN THE
INCITEMENT OF A VIOLENT ACT,
EVEN WITHOUT EXPRESS ORDERS TO
ATTACK THAT PERSON OR GROUP.
WHEN LEADERS, WHETHER ELECTED OR
IN MEDIA OR IN A MOVEMENT, WHEN
LEADERS CLAIM THAT THEIR
OPPONENTS ARE PEDOPHILES OR
SATANISTS OR A PART OF A GRAND
CONSPIRACY TO HURT YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY, IS ANYONE REALLY
SURPRISED WHEN SOMEBODY WHO
HEARS THIS ACTS?
WHAT EXACTLY DO YOU THINK IS
GOING TO HAPPEN WHEN A PRESIDENT
FOR MONTHS LIES TO HIS
SUPPORTERS THAT AN ELECTION IS
BEING STOLEN?
WHAT EXACTLY DO YOU THINK IS
GOING TO HAPPEN WHEN SMEAR
ARTISTS INVENT A DERANGED
CONSPIRACY THEORY ABOUT HILLARY
CLINTON AND HER CAMPAIGN AND
NON-EXISTENT CHILD SEX
OPERATIONS AT THE BASEMENT OF A
VERY REAL FAMILY PIZZERIA.
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS?
A GUY WITH A GUN DRIVES FROM
NORTH CAROLINA TO THAT PIZZERIA.
>> I HOPE ALL THESE PEOPLE
FANNING THE FLAMES OF THIS
CONSPIRACY TAKE A MOMENT TO FAN
THE FLAMES OF WHAT HAS GONE ON
HERE TODAY AND MAYBE TO STOP.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING TO
HAPPEN WHEN POLITICIANS AND TV
ANCHORS PUSH THE GREAT
REPLACEMENT THEORY, THE IDEA
THAT JEWS WANT TO REPLACE WHITES
IN AMERICA WITH LATINOS AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR?
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS?
THAT DERANGED CONSPIRACY THEORY
INSPIRES THE ATTACKS IN
PITTSBURGH, EL PASO, THE RACIST
BUFFALO SUPERMARKET SHOOTING.
>> IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT LAYING
EYES ON THE PERSON WHO SHOT YOUR
MOTHER DOWN IN A GROCERY STORE.
>> PAUL PELOSI, TO HIS ATTACKER,
WAS NOT A GRANDFATHER OR A
FATHER OR A HUSBAND OR A
BUSINESSMAN.
HE WAS AN ENEMY.
WHILE SPEAKING TODAY ON THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE ATTACK,
THE SAN FRANCISCO POLICE CHIEF
POSED AN IMPORTANT QUESTION FOR
ALL OF US AS AMERICANS.
>> WHAT DOES IT TAKE?
DOES IT TAKE SOMEBODY BEING
MURDERED?
DOES IT TAKE -- WHAT DOES IT
TAKE FOR US TO FINALLY STAND UP
AND SAY, THIS IS ENOUGH?
IT NEEDS TO STOP.
>> IT'S NOT JUST FOLKS IN THE
POLITICAL ARENA PLAYING FAST AND
LOOSE WITH THESE DANGEROUS
IDEAS.
TAKE KANYE WEST, NOW YE, HIS
RESPONSE TO CRITICISM TO MANY
ANTI-SEMITIC COMMENTS HAS BEEN
TO MAKE MORE OF THEM.
GOT HIM SUSPENDED FROM INSTAGRAM
AGAIN LAST NIGHT.
AND ALARMINGLY THERE ARE A LOT
OF PEOPLE ON SOCIAL MEDIA TAKING
YE'S SIDE ON THIS.
NBA STAR KYRIE IRVING OF THE
BROOKLYN NETS TWEETED A LINK TO
A WIDELY DEBUNKED ANTI-SEMITIC
MOVIE FULL OF LIES AND JUST
JUNK.
HE WAS NOT APOLOGETIC AT ALL AT
A SATURDAY PRESS CONFERENCE.
>> THERE'S THINGS BEING POSTED
EVERY DAY.
I'M NO DIFFERENT THAN THE NEXT
HUMAN BEING, SO DON'T TREAT ME
ANY DIFFERENT.
>> THE NEXT HUMAN BEING DOESN'T
HAVE 4.6 MILLION TWITTER
FOLLOWERS, KYRIE, AT A TIME OF
RISING ANTI-SEMITIC VIOLENCE.
I DO NOT KNOW WHAT IS MISSING IN
THESE PEOPLE'S HEARTS OR THEIR
LIVES THAT THEY FEEL THE NEED TO
SMEAR INDIVIDUALS OR GROUPS, TO
IGNORE THE HUMANITY OF THESE
OTHER PEOPLE.
BUT IN ONE WAY, YOU KNOW, KYRIE
IRVING IS RIGHT.
HE IS NO DIFFERENT.
HE MIGHT HAV